we're told the parabola given by y is
equal to three x squared minus six x
plus one and the line given by y minus x
plus one equals zero our graph so you
can see the parabola here in red and we
can see the line here in blue and the
first thing they ask us is one
intersection point is clearly
identifiable from the graph what is it
and they want us to put it in here this
is actually a screenshot from the
exercise on khan academy but i'm just
going to write on it if you're doing it
on khan academy you would type it in but
pause this video and see if you can
answer this first part
all right so one intersection point is
clearly identifiable from the graph i
see two intersection points i see that
one and i see that one there this second
one seems clearly identifiable because
when i look at the grid it looks clearly
to be at a value of x equals 2 and y
equals 1. it seems to be the point 2
comma 1. so it's 2 comma 1 there and
what's interesting about these
intersection points is because it's a
point that sits on the graph of both of
these curves that means that it
satisfies both of these equations that
it's a solution to both of these
equations so the other one is find the
other intersection point your answer
must be exact so they want us to figure
out this
intersection point right over here well
to do that we're gonna we're gonna have
to try to solve this system of equations
and this is interesting because this is
a system of equations where one of the
equations is not linear where it is a
quadratic so let's see how we could go
about doing that so let me write down
the equations i have y
is equal to 3x squared minus 6x plus 1.
and our next equation right over here y
y
minus x plus 1 is equal to 0.
well one way to tackle and this is one
way to tackle any system of equations is
through substitution so if i can rewrite
this linear equation as in terms of y if
i can solve for y then i can substitute
what y equals back into my first
equation into my quadratic one and then
hopefully i can solve for x so let's
solve for y here actually let me color
code it because this one is in red
and
this one
is the line in that blue color
so let's just solve for y the easiest
way to solve for y is to add x to both
sides
and subtract 1 from both sides
that was hard to see
so and subtract 1 from both sides and so
we are going to get
y
and then all the rest of the stuff
cancels out is equal to
x
minus 1.
and so now we can substitute x minus 1
back in for y and so we get x minus 1
is
equal to
3 x squared minus 6x
plus 1.
now we can we want to get a 0 on one
side of this equation so let's subtract
x i'll do this in a neutral color now
let's subtract x from both sides and
let's add 1 to both sides
and then what do we get
on the left hand side we just get
0
and on the right hand side we get 3x
squared
minus seven x plus two so this is equal
to zero
now we could try to factor this let's
see is there an obvious way to factor it
can i think of two numbers
a
times b that's equal to the product of
three and two
three times two and if this looks
unfamiliar you can review factoring by
grouping and can i think of those same
two a plus b where it's going to be
equal to negative 7
and actually
negative 6 and negative 1 work so i can
what i can do is i can rewrite this
whole thing as 0 is equal to 3x squared
and then instead of negative 7x i can
write negative 6x
and minus x and then i have my plus 2.
i'm just factoring by grouping for those
of you who are not familiar with this
technique you could also use a quadratic
formula
so then 0 is equal to so if i group
these first two i can factor out a 3x so
i'm going to get 3x
times x
minus 2
and in these second two i can factor out
in these second two i can factor out a
negative one so i have negative one
times x minus two and then i can factor
out a negative two i'll scroll down a
little bit so i have some space
so i have
zero
is equal to if i factor out an x minus 2
i'm going to get x minus 2
times 3 x
minus 1.
and so a solution would be a situation
where either of these is equal to zero
or i'll scroll down a little bit more
so x minus two could be equal to zero or
three x minus one is equal to zero the
point which x minus two equals zero is
when x is equal to two and for 3x minus
1 equals 0 add 1 to both sides you get
3x is equal to 1 or x is equal to 1 3.
so we figured out the we already saw the
solution where x is equals equals 2.
that's this point right over here we
already typed that in but now we figured
out the x value of the other solution so
this is x is equal to 1 3 right over
here so our x value is 1 3 but we still
have to figure out the y value well the
y value is going to be the corresponding
y we get for that x in either equation
and i like to focus on the simpler of
the two equations so we can figure out
what is x
when or what is y when x is equal to 1 3
using this equation we could have used
the original one but this is even
simpler it's already solved for y so y
is equal to 1 3
minus 1. i'm just substituting that
one-third back into this and so you get
y is equal to negative two-thirds and it
looks like that as well y is equal to
negative two-thirds right over there so
this is the point one-third comma
negative two-thirds and we're done